[Music]
it is one of the big questions that
everyone is asking about Prince Harry
and Megan Marcos voice wedding which
superstar will perform and wait until
you hear the new detail that we just
found out oh it's exciting news yeah the
wedding is still about three months away
on May the 19th but we now have a clear
picture of what is going to happen on a
big day
[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan will tie the knot
at noon
that's 7:00 a.m. Eastern Time if you're
watching from home the wedding will
happen inside historic st. George's
Chapel it's a much more intimate setting
than Westminster Abbey where William and
Kate were married the abbey seats 2,000
people since george's chapel only seats
around 800 guests unfortunately Windsor
Castle doesn't have a balcony like
Buckingham Palace so we're not going to
get to see a kiss like we did with
William and Kate like we did with
Charles and Diana and Andrew and Fergie
after the service at 1 p.m. at carriage
procession and Harry and Megan's first
public appearance as husband and wife
they'll probably be in the same carriage
William and Kate rode in after their
wedding in 2011 as well as Prince
Charles and Lady Diana in 1981 his
carriage procession is a real treat this
one is going to be two miles long and it
really incorporates a lot of Windsor the
procession ends back at the castle for a
reception around 3 p.m. at st. George's
Hall since George's Hall is a
spectacular setting and it's most often
used for glittering state banquets and
we have new details about who may
perform the news kissmes a source tells
ET that Ed Sheeran has been asked to
sing a few songs nothing new
no word yet on if he has accepted but he
told Kelty this in December are you
going to sing at the row wedding yeah I
mean if you know the time if I if I was
free I probably would
[Music]